I just have to say I watched this movie
in a big theater it was packed and
everybody was laughing out loud so such
a fun experience for me
um the music video for gonna be you just
dropped which is on the soundtrack so
Jane I wanted to know what's it like
having your good friend Dolly Parton be
a part of this film
I didn't even know she was going to do
it until I went and saw we all saw the
movie in Palm Springs and I was so
thrilled and happy and excited just
wonderful
Sally I have to ask I'm sure everyone's
been asking you about Tom Brady feeling
chemistry for you on Set uh is it funny
that it's turned into this thing where
everyone wants you to date Tom
yeah I mean I I I'm still well what
um I I um that's very nice I'm very very
flattered I don't this isn't nonsense
because I'm I'm I've made him a peanut
butter sandwich in a hard-boiled I even
put in a paper bag to send him to school
I mean I could be you know I could do
that
okay don't even ask me anymore clearly
I'm pickled bald by this I mean I'm just
like
okay that's so nice
that's amazing listen now I want a
peanut butter sandwich and a hard-boiled
egg this is great
um uh Rita you said that this is one of
the best experiences you've had in your
life what made these ladies so special
for you in this film they're right here
those are the reasons I mean when I was
told who was in it before I joined I was
flabbergasted I said really they're
really gonna do a movie I mean it didn't
matter even what it was about look at
you look at this so that was easy that
was the easiest part of all oh I love
that
um Lily you know your character draws so
much inspiration from someone like a Tom
Brady is there someone in your life an
actor that you've worked with or someone
that you've met in the industry over the
years that you were kind of in awe that
you have this very vivid memory of
meeting them for the first time
um
probably not for Spiritual reasons but
when I first met Dorothy Malone
the actress really I was I just had gone
to my first um
what what what up fronts no no it would
be like a big thing Gathering where show
people come and they all get different
Awards because the Oscars
no it was like you know they were like
third rung at that time like Golden
Globe she was gorgeous yes and you met
her she because when I was a girl in the
50s yeah uh she was the sexy bad girl
absolutely and Barbara Rush was the sexy
good girl yeah oh that's right they
defined uh my Pathways in life yeah that
and when I heard Dorothy Malone was in
that whole car this configuration yeah
melange of people I ran across the the
people there was an act on the stage or
so I think I ran across the the
performance area and I threw up in her
door and uh she was standing there full
naked naked that's how it sounds right
she wasn't naked but uh
I mean you know just to clear things up
in the moment she was not naked and
so um I was gratified that's so nice
was she nice very nice she was kind of
shy yeah and kind of a surprise that a
person
of course into her room right
I love that okay well then I have to ask
who had the strongest reaction meeting
Tom Brady for the first time I did
no I I had a much more Humane human
personal age-appropriate reaction which
was I related to him like a a mother a
sister somebody that was so proud of him
because he was such a large boy man and
so perfectly formed perfectly formed and
his face is his face is so boyish she's
so it is incredibly it looks like an
enormous extraordinary athlete one one
of the most extraordinary athletes that
ever lived in I personally came out and
offered everybody coffee and said how
are you all glad you're here and that
was my role and I I've never seen anyone
that looked like a huge boy
he's a huge boy yeah
we had to lean down a little bit when he
came into my dressing room that's called
Baby Huey
but I love that he's good and Jane you
reacted totally different oh yeah my
knees don't do that not not for someone
like Tom I I don't why did you answer
before me they don't know anything about
knees yet I haven't given any answer
she's asking me a question oh I'm he
walked into my trailer and my knees gave
way and yes my knees give way a lot
hahaha
okay well this has been one of my
favorite interviews ever uh thank you so
much you guys were so so fantastic in
this honestly I want another movie of
all four of you so thanks guys thank you
okay thank you I bet you're on the money